from their breakout in the 1970s the
mothers have been a cultural touchstone
for so many there's never a bad time to
appreciate the ways in which they have
continued to impress and engage in adult
audience despite their appearance as
children's fair here are some things you
might have missed as a kid the original
The Muppet movie is a brilliant and fun
origin story that for the most part is
timeless however there are some ways in
which it is very much a product of its
time such as the running kari krishna
joke harry krishna is a religious
movement founded in 1966 and a natural
fit for those within the hippie movement
in other words it was a perfect punch
line for a 1970s comedy The Muppet movie
opens have come at the Frog sitting on a
log in a swamp happily playing his banjo
is interrupted by a man played by Dom
DeLuise frantically paddling a canoe and
exclaiming that he's lost his sense of
direction
Kermit immediately suggests and thus the
gag begins
not long after Kermit is observing
Fozzie Bear stand-up routine and mutters
to himself this guy is lost the barkeep
behind him says at this point Kermit
breaks the fourth wall and verbalizes
what everyone is thinking finally after
driving for hours and hours on their way
to make it big in Los Angeles Kermit and
Fozzie pull over to run down church for
a well-deserved rest the sign outside
the church says lost
have you tried Reverend Harry Krishna
completing the gag and observing the
comedic rule of three more the adults in
the audience would be aware of this
movement is unlikely that kids would
catch any of the Muppets religious jokes
ever since they first arrived in the 70s
the Muppets a busser audience to be
somewhat conversant with the tropes of
TV and movies and while kids might
totally understand that the sketch pigs
in space is a reference to Star Trek
they're less likely to see the
similarities to lost in space especially
if we're talking about modern day
audiences however even kids back in the
70s probably wouldn't get that the
character of dr. strange pork is named
for the Stanley Kubrick film dr.
Strangelove these homage to classic
films and TV shows might be lost on
younger viewers but they've continued
for decades
most recently the Alien franchise was
referenced drawing a pig's and space
sketch where Pepe the king prawns
prizes accrue and pops in for a guest
appearance I don't know who you are
buddy
but your stomach is a dump Julie like a
peak seeing as how the Muppets became
popular in the 1970s it makes sense of
references to rock and hippie culture a
baked into many of the characters most
notably the members of dr. teeth and the
Electric Mayhem this ragtag group of
musicians include bassist and singer
Floyd Pepper whose name is a tribute to
the British rock band the Pink Floyd as
well as the Beatles album Sgt pepper's
Lonely Hearts Club Band on top of all
that guitarist and singer Janice for the
lethargic spaced out voice drooping
eyelids and bell-bottom jeans as a
stereotypical stoned flower child guys
in the band and during their performance
of the song can you picture that in the
Muppet movie the band helps disguise
Kermit and Fozzie scar by painting it in
psychedelic rainbow colors very typical
of them but more perplexing to Kermit
with their eccentric personalities the
Electric Mayhem surely appealed to kids
but their specific callback to free love
and rock music might have been more
obvious to children of the 70s the
Muppets have never shied away from
joking about the birds and the beasts of
course these references were never lewd
and always between fully mature frogs
pigs chickens and whatever gonzo is one
of the few instances of the Muppets
overtly spelling thing Sal's was drawing
the opening sequence of an early pilot
show which had a very suggestive title
then there's the entire episode of The
Muppet Show with Raquel Welch which run
the sauciness factor up to 11 there was
a dance number with an eight-legged
freak an intimate serenade with a
smitten Fozzie Bear and a duet between
Welch and piggy about the power of
womanhood the episode even includes some
implications about Kermit's and Piggy's
private life tonight we have an
internationally acclaimed actress singer
dancer and one of the sexiest ladies
alive also one of the Muppets most
popular characters animal is of walking
grunting drumming embodiment of the EDD
acting on all is most base needs without
consideration or remorse he has a
penchant for exclaiming woman any time
he sees a member of the opposite sex he
finds appealing and he wastes no time
before chasing them around and who can
forget gonzo Anders
ending attraction to chickens after many
years it seems like gonzo has finally
settled down and is currently cooped up
in a long-term relationship with Camilla
the beaky romantics are clearly in love
with each other even though some of
their peers seem to think them as an odd
couple a beautiful scene between a man
and a woman but really weird between
your blood room mate and a chicken who
the Muppets have always loved their
guest stars but while some cameos are
aimed towards children
others were purely for grownups that's
especially true when it comes to the
Muppet Show the classic TV series have
featured a new celebrity guest every
episode well kids back in the day
definitely would have appreciated
watching Sylvester Stallone or Mark
Hamill chances are pretty good that they
would have been baffled to see Russian
ballet dancer Rudolf Nureyev performing
swine Lake with a human size Pig another
unexpected guest was Vincent Price a
classic horror fixture who allowed his
silliness to mix with his sinister side
in one of the show's Halloween specials
along these same lines the Muppets
welcome Chuck rocker Alice Cooper who
oddly enough felt like a perfect fit for
the show with his larger-than-life
personality and flair for theatrics Plus
Rita Moreno one of the few people to win
an Oscar Emmy Tony and Grammy Award
showed off her voice and perfect comic
timing in a musical standoff with animal
however if kids of the 70s had trouble
identifying these stars you can bet that
modern-day children would be completely
baffled when we visiting the show but
you never know every so often you meet a
really cool kid you would have the
perfect reaction to any of these classic
muppet moments check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]